Film Courage: What did writing your first
screenplay teach you about screenwriting?
Mark Harris, Filmmaker: Oh, gosh!
So when I wrote my first screenplay…now
this is the different between writing a first
screenplay and when I was directing.
When I wrote my first screenplay of course
Syd Field is like…I don’t think you can
really be a solid screenwriter if you haven’t
studied Syd Field.
I’ve read a lot of screenplays, tons of
screenplays before I even started writing
screenplays.
I’ve read Syd Field’s book and I continue
to read his books.
But tons of screenplays.
When I wrote my first screenplay (and it never
got produced of course) and I took it out
and people read it, it was pretty decent but
it wasn’t good.
It was only after writing at least 10 screenplays
before I actually produced my own stuff.
But it taught me a lot.
That I didn’t play with at all because I
knew that in order to sit down and write there
had to be a particular structure.
And that’s one of the things too is that,
one of these things is very important as screenwriters
and filmmakers is that when you’re pitching
to producers you have to make sure that the
screenplay is properly structured, use Final
Draft and we have to really, really invest
in ourselves and in our craft.
Go out and get the Final Draft program, go
out and read Syd Field’s book and know how
to read screenplays.
And make sure that when you actually pitch
to producers that it’s properly formatted.
There is nothing worse than someone saying
they have an idea and they pitch you an idea
but they want you to write the idea.
Like I have tons of screenplays of my own
or screenwriters who want you to read their
screenplays but it’s not properly formatted,
I’ve had that.
Recently someone asked me to read their screenplay,
they had the heading and it was written like
a play.
I’m like there’s a difference between
a screenplay and a stage play.
And I don’t think people understand that
when you’re writing a screenplay, it’s
formatted a particular way because when you
are dealing with different set ups those are
very important.
And I had to explain it to the person.
He’s like “Just read it.”
I was like “For me as a filmmaker, that’s
hard to follow.”
When you don’t have the proper headings
on it like INTERIOR: I don’t know where
I’m at in the story.
I can’t follow it.
But those are very important because now this
is one set-up, we go outside that’s a different
set-up.
So you have to make sure that it’s in the
screenplay as an exterior so I’ve read screenplays
where they don’t have that.
It’s like there’s no way.
And people don’t understand because they
think you’re hating because they’re making
it difficult to read their screenplay because
they don’t want to follow the proper structure.
You follow the proper structure and it will
make it much easier for us to read your screenplay.
Film Courage: How was it for you to get your
first feedback because you spoke of feedback
earlier in the interview and how it’s important.
Was the first time you showed someone your
screenplay, what was that feedback?
Mark: The feedback I got was…again it’s
something that you have to grow and evolve
but when somebody tells you this is not properly
done or the story is not connecting, you are
like “Why?
Why?”
You get offended by it.
But the thing is we can’t be because if
we want to grow and evolve, we have to listen
to constructive criticism.
And if someone is giving you some constructive
criticism, I know it’s hard for us to deal
with it, it was hard for me to deal with it.
It’s like still today I have to be more
open-minded when people read my screenplays.
You have to train your mind or keep telling
myself that this is necessary, this feedback
is necessary.
I was just watching the movie THE WIFE.
Film Courage: Oh yes!
Excellent.
Mark: Excellent movie.
And when his wife gave him that feedback he
just blew up, right?
He didn’t want other that feedback.
But at the end of the day if he had listened
to her, he probably would have become a better
writer instead of what happened.
But we have to listen to those voices that
give us that constructive criticism so we
can evolve.
I know it’s difficult.
Even today, when I’m letting someone read
my screenplay and they’re giving me feedback
on it, I have to keep telling myself over
and over again “This is necessary.”
When that feedback is difficult to hear, just
repeat “I need this.”
Because it’s very important.
It’s to allow us to grow and evolve and
just put the ego aside.
We have to put that ego aside at all times
even while on set, put the ego aside and listen
to the people who can make our projects better.